today on the matt walsh show the biden
administration goes for gold in the woke
olympics by appointing a genderfluid
drag queen dog fetishist to a
high-ranking federal post
yes we'll have more information about
that also speaking of sexual degeneracy
parents in one school district are
outraged after their young children were
given an assignment
asking them to list their sexual desires
and preferences and comparing it to
pizza we'll have to explain that one as
well and a new disney junior show
teaches kids about microaggressions
through song plus many democrats have
changed their tune about masking what
accounts for the sudden conversion
finally in our daily cancellation we'll
discuss what might be the most horrific
story of racism you'll ever hear and it
happened in a gucci store and the victim
is a rapper all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
you know the pro-life movement must
maintain its momentum now more than ever
and what better way to help than by
supporting the charities and causes you
care about even the supreme court were
to strike down roe v wade abortion you
know tomorrow abortion would still exist
in america in many states charity mobile
then is the pro-life phone company that
you should be supporting they partner
with you to automatically support the
pro-life pro-family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and have sent millions of
dollars to charities so far new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh certain restrictions apply
charity mobile makes it easy to switch
you can keep your existing phone number
and you might even be able to keep your
existing phone but if you need a new
phone no problem there charity mobile
has a variety of options from the latest
5g phones to low-cost smartphones and
basic flip phones as well they even have
a phone with parental controls that
allows you to disable and password
protect wi-fi and cellular data usage
text messaging picture messaging and
more uh and if you have kids then i
would i would
plead with you to take advantage of that
option if you're getting them a phone
all of their monthly plans include
unlimited domestic minutes and messages
which can be shared by up to eight lines
on a family plan no contracts no
termination fees and no risk with a
30-day money-back guarantee great live
customer support and great nationwide
coverage on america's most reliable
network so switch to charity mobile and
support the causes you care about call
them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh as western civilization
marches inexorably into collapse and
extinction many landmarks uh kind of
mark our way our path as we go along
many unprecedented events and historic
moments occur as we get nearer and
nearer to the edge of the cliff we find
that we pass these signposts with
greater frequency and so history was
made yet again this week though you may
not have heard about it according to
multiple reports the bind administration
has hired a man named sam brinton to an
important and high level post at the
department of energy britain will be the
deputy assistant secretary of spend fuel
and waste disposition
in the office of nuclear energy where he
will be tasked with the important role
of as the title suggests disposing of
nuclear waste this is the kind of thing
that you would want to entrust to only
the sanest and most clear-headed sort of
person
but instead biden has decided to use
this appointment
as another opportunity to earn woke
points from the far left
britain as it turns out is a long-time
lgbt activist most recently he was the
head of advocacy and government affairs
for a gay rights group called the trevor
project where he worked on important
issues like pronouns listen
i use they and them as my pronouns and
when someone uses
they and them as my pronouns i feel like
that person is listening to me that
person cares about me and that person
wants to have a conversation with me
[Music]
[Music]
pronouns are
a
fascinating part of modern culture i
don't think many people think about them
very often until someone like myself or
others
say
their pronouns
so when i introduce myself i generally
say hi my name is sam britton i use they
in them as my pronouns and i serve as
head of advocacy and government affairs
for the trevor project
you know why they always dress like they
just raided the wardrobe at a
you know
tim burton film or something
his extensive experience promoting
pronoun usage has undoubtedly prepared
him to run a division within the
department of energy of course but we
haven't even scratched the woke surface
when it comes to sam britton
on his own twitter account britain brags
that he will be to his knowledge the
first gender fluid person appointed to a
position of leadership in the federal
government but he sells himself himself
a little short i think he's uh not just
the first gender fluid person to hold a
high ranking position in the government
mostly because there is no such thing as
being gender fluid he is though as far
as i know the first drag queen and dog
fetishist
now we know that bill clinton was into
some weird stuff so it's possible that
britain's appointment is not as historic
as it might seem but we can certainly
say that he is the first person in a
high-ranking federal post to be open
about these things at least
and he is indeed
very open
all too open
the national pulse reports quote a
recent high level of uh higher at the
department of energy energy's office of
nuclear energy is a drag queen lgbtq
plus activist who has lectured on kink
at college campuses and participated in
interviews about fetish role play in one
interview sam brinton now a top biden
official even discusses having sex with
animals he also goes by sister ray
dioactive
his drag queen alter ego in his own
website's bio britain reveals quote sam
has worn his stilettos to congress to
advise legislators about nuclear policy
and to the white house where he advised
president obama and michelle obama on
lgbt issues he shows young men and women
everywhere that everywhere he goes that
they can be who they are and gives them
courage once while he was walking around
disney world and six-inch stilettos with
his boyfriend a young gay boy saw sam
with his boyfriend and started crying he
told his mother it's true mom
we can be our own princesses here
yeah i'm sure this guy's
caused a lot of children to
bust out in tears when they when they
see him um
an inspiring story though specifically
what it inspires is nausea and it gets
worse back to the national pulse it says
britain is an active member of the
washington dc chapter of a drag queen
society known as the sisters of
perpetual indulgence which lists him as
the principal contact on its 2016-2018
tax forms during the group's lavender
mass 2021 britain can be seen referring
to anthony fauci who was declared a
saint as daddy fauci in a separate
interview britain explains how he role
plays as a pup handler
britain explains quote i actually have
trouble when we transition from pup play
to having sex
like no i can't have you whimper like
that when we're having sex he says
because i don't want to mix that world
it's interesting because he doesn't have
to come out of pup mode to have me have
sex with him i personally have to bring
him out of pup perception for me but
that i'm still treating him as a
submissive to me
you know i've always scoffed at the idea
of trigger warnings but that might have
been an occasion to use one too late now
sorry about that
now if you for some reason want some
pictures to go along with those
descriptions journalist andy noe
provides them here and you can see
if you're watching this on video you can
see brenton with his gay lovers in
leather dog masks and leashes um
these must be the dog-faced pony
soldiers that biden warned us about
if only we had listened so this is who
we will who will be in charge of nuclear
waste disposal over at the department of
energy
the good news is that when we have our
own chernobyl the eventual hbo
miniseries about it will be
even more interesting meanwhile many
people on social media have defended
britain from criticism
saying that his sex life is none of our
business
you know it's it's not relevant to the
work he was hired to do
and we shouldn't kink shame him
the problem with that argument of course
is that he has made his sex life our
business
he has spent years advertising it
posting photographs doing interviews and
so on
so if you don't want anyone to know
about or comment on your sexual
proclivities then don't stand on the
street corner with a bull horn shouting
hey guys let me tell you about my sexual
proclivities
and especially don't do it with a
leather dog mask on
but of course as always with lgbt
activists they very much want the public
to know about their sex lives and to
have opinions about their sex lives it's
just that they only want us to have one
specific opinion which is an opinion of
approval affirmation and celebration
unfortunately for them it doesn't work
that way
see when you submit a certain fact about
yourself to the public
when you say to the public hey let me
tell you about myself isn't that
interesting
you don't get to assign them an opinion
ahead of time
you don't get to say to someone a
stranger here i'm going to give you this
fact about myself
and before i tell you here's the only
opinion you're allowed to have about it
no you've opened yourself up for
whatever judgment people feel like
making
and no matter what the judgment is
you're not a victim
because they can have whatever opinion
they want
and the judgment in this case about a
drag queen dog fetishist
is going to be among many people and
ought to be
rather negative
now is it relevant to the job that he's
supposed to do
does this even matter
well it does because only a mentally
unbalanced and severely sick person
would have any desire to dress someone
up in a leather dog outfit and walk them
around on a leash
there's a sentence one of many that i
never thought i'd have to say
only such a person would be sexually
tantalized by the idea of someone
pretending to be a dog i mean this is
i i shouldn't have to tell you this is
bestiality you know this is you're
attracted to someone because they're
pretending to be a dog
your personal life is is going to
actually be the best reflection of who
you are as a person that's why we call
it your personal life
and the reflection in sam britton's case
is quite horrifying
this is to say nothing of the national
security risks of having someone like
this anywhere near nuclear material
the concern isn't so much what he would
do with that material i mean that's part
of the concern
but even more so what a country like
china might be able to do with someone
like him
i mean just think
we know what britain has made public
about himself
now just imagine what he has not made
public
i mean for this guy this the the things
that that he advertises
the things about his life that he says
oh yeah everyone should know about this
i mean what are the things where he says
oh i'm not going to tell anybody about
this
i don't know what they are
but imagine if china discovers those
things
putting the drag queen and the dog
outfit into a position of leadership in
the department of energy is a big
blinking neon sign shouting hey china
please blackmail this guy
besides the final point here is let's
remember how the left treated people
like amy coney barrett
mike pence
their personal lives
their beliefs about sex
were considered very relevant
the dogma lives loudly within you who
can forget that phrase tammy coney
barrett
and what were those beliefs
well simply that people should get
married stay married and only have sex
with their own spouses
these what we must now call traditional
attitudes about sex were meant to be
disqualifying
and yet a man who fantasizes about
having sex with dogs
ought not be disqualified
now you see it's not that the left
thinks sex is private
and has no relevance to the public far
from it
they've done more than anyone to make
sex into a public affair in more ways
than one
no it's that there is a certain
extremely depraved set of ideas about
sex
that they want to promote and normalize
and that's what this guy's appointment
is obviously really about
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i don't know about you but i hate being
lied to it just fills me with rage and
it happens enough with the left that it
should be happening with my food as well
if i can't trust my food then who
in this world can i trust but it turns
out that 85 percent of the grass-fed
beef in the u.s is imported from
overseas and here's the lie
these foreign products are often labeled
product of usa since they're minimally
processed here that's how they that's
the loophole they get through but don't
pay a premium for low quality foreign
meat good rancher sells 100 american
meat and delivers it to your door for a
great price they only sell 100 american
meat sourced from local american farms
their beef is prime and upper choice the
highest quality possible they've got rib
eyes they've got t-bones they've got new
york strips and much more the best thing
about about good ranchers is that the
food is just really really good head on
over to goodranchers.com walsh today to
solve your meat problem once and for all
get the transparency quality and cuts
you've been craving order now with code
walsh to get 30 off your box now's the
time to support american farms and
ranches they're hurting and you're
hungry so solve both of those problems
with a box of american meat delivered
whoever buys the meat in your house
needs to go to goodranchers.com
walsh today
um the other question about sam britton
and uh and his appointment to the you
know the nuclear division over the
department of energy is whether anyone
in the republican party
will have the minimal courage required
to
criticize it or say anything about it
because we know as as discussed with the
democrats when it came to mike pence
they were they were very eager to say i
don't know this guy only has sex with
his wife
seems a little suspicious
i don't know i don't know if he's cut
out for this job
um well will any republican
stand up and say hey you know what um
i'm actually not okay with the dog
fetishes drag queen
gender fluid guy having this position
probably not as it stands right now this
is he's put into that position totally
unopposed
all right um let's unfortunately stay in
the same theme here of sexual degeneracy
um
reading now from uh uh tim poole's
website timcast.com
says a connecticut school is being
criticized for sending eighth graders an
assignment requiring them to compare
their preferred pizza toppings to their
sexual preferences
the school is now calling this
assignment a mistake
students at john f kennedy middle school
in enfield recently received the pizza
and consent assignment the assignment
asked students to compare their favorite
pizza toppings to their favorite sex
acts
um i think in fact we have a mother of
one of these kids she spoke to the the
board of education about it and she has
a little bit more information about it
let's let's listen to this clip
just last week a school assignment in
jfk labeled pizza and consent was sent
out for students what's pizza got to do
with it you wonder we can use pizza as a
metaphor for sex those are the first two
lines of this assignment which is
centered around establishing consent and
boundaries except for page two where it
takes it one step further and states now
that you know the metaphor for sex let's
explore your preference draw and color
your favorite type of pizza mirror these
preferences in relation to sex here are
some examples likes cheese equals
kissing dislikes olives equals giving
oral since when has become acceptable
for a teacher to ask a student what
their sexual wants desires and
boundaries are maybe our board members
would like to answer this assignment and
share their thoughts just like our 8th
grade students were requested to do no
do you object and find it incredibly
uncomfortable when we reached out for
clarification we were informed that the
incorrect version of this assignment was
posted in the curriculum by mistake and
inadvertently used for instruction in
the classes the coordinator claimed to
have caught the error in june but failed
to post the edited version intended for
instruction why didn't the teachers that
taught this assignment catch it and
question it did they just teach the
curriculum blindly not questioning the
morality of assignments required for the
unit
oh so that's that's their excuse is that
it was a mistake
and what what what kind of accident oh
we tripped and fell and accidentally uh
sexually groomed children i mean what
how is this an accident it's very very
much intentional this was something they
obviously meant to do the only as always
when you hear about uh mistakes when
there's a when there's some some
horrific thing
that makes its way into the curriculum
and then the the school board members
the teachers and the administrators say
oh it was a mistake
no the mistake was parents finding out
about it
that was the mistake
um because they
the kids aren't supposed to go home and
tell the parents
right
parents aren't supposed to know about
that
this is why the left has been very clear
that this this is it's none of your
business what happens at the school
you shouldn't have any say in that
that's that's up to the teachers
so the mistake is that uh they found out
and
i mean i'm not even going to try to
understand
uh
the
some of the specifics here
so
talk about your sexual preferences and
then and then
and how they relate to pizza top
toppings what
so each sex act is analogous to a pizza
topping
so
what what what does sam britain like on
his pizza how do we what which pizza
topping does that compare to i wonder
but when we see all of this
well we have to remember we talked about
this in uh backstage last night actually
is um
and it's and it's good that that parents
are waking up to this now
and are becoming aware and they're
speaking out and that's a very good
thing
it's just unfortunate
that
we're about 60 years late
better late than never i mean it's good
that we're starting now
but all of this
as i explained last night all of this
was inevitable
the moment that comprehensive what they
what they used to call i suppose they
still call comprehensive sex education
once that became um
ubiquitous in the school system once
that made it into every curriculum every
every school in the country which it has
been for decades now
once that happened all of this was
inevitable this is a logical extension
of that
and as bad as this is
i mean you're asking eighth graders
not only are you talking to them about
the sexuality and sexual preferences but
you're asking them to specifically tell
you
what their sexual desires are
you're an adult talking to children
asking for their sexual desires
you go up to a kid on the street
you take one of these teachers
and um put them in in civilian clothes
out just walking on the street
and they go up to an eighth grader and
say hey uh little kid can you tell me
about your sexual desires
you do that and it's
you're going to prison for that
now you're now you're on the sex
offender registry
but put the kid behind a desk
and put you also behind a desk
in
in the in a classroom and now all of a
sudden it's okay
no of course not
but as bad as this is it's not that much
worse
it's worse only by a matter of a few
degrees from um the kind of thing that
they were doing in sex ed classes when i
was going to school
or back in the 90s
this is the logical extension of
comprehensive sex ed
the moment we went from
let's tell kids
just about the birds and the bees where
babies come from
human anatomy the biology of sexual
reproduction okay
of course that's going to be
in the curriculum that's part of science
that's part of anatomy you know and at a
certain age when they get to a certain
point
kids are going to learn about that
they're going to learn about
reproduction but the moment we went from
learning about the scientific facts of
sexual reproduction
to
um the the teachers and the school
system they're going to
you know impart
certain views certain a value system
about the sexual act itself
so it went from reproduction to here are
the attitudes
that you should have about sex
once that threshold was crossed
all of the rest of this was going to
follow
inevitably
and the problem is that for years and
decades even
yeah there have always been some
conservatives criticizing comprehensive
sexual sex ed sex ed on these grounds
but for years they were shouted down as
prudes and puritans
and now a lot of the people that were
doing the shouting
are outraged
and they're showing up the school boards
outrage and i'm glad they are but it's
too bad that you're 20 30 40 years late
and this is not just about i told you so
this is more like
next time
try to catch on to these things much
sooner
all right this is from politico it says
democrats are making a u-turn on mass
mandates just in time for the midterms
it's happening among the party's
governors several of whom are easing up
their masking rules as covid's omicron
wave fades and it's happening on the
hill where democrats are suddenly lining
up to call for rollbacks of the nation's
most noticeable pandemic era rule their
pandemic pivot comes as they brace for a
brutal november election in which the
virus is shaping up to be democrats
biggest blind spot
many in the party are now coming around
to what swing district lawmakers have
privately warned for weeks that the buy
administration needs to drastically
rethink its handling of code
particularly in the suburbs those
vulnerable democrats worry that ugly
clashes over math school closings and
vaccine mandates will crush them in
purple districts this fall and it will
and there's nothing they could do to
stop it now thank god
um
and as as more and more school districts
and states get away from masking
we're starting to see how kids are
reacting to that so i just want to play
play one clip for you here's a class in
an elementary school in nevada
when they they first learn
that the mask mandate has been
lifted and these kids look like they're
i don't know in first or second grade
and uh here's how they react to it watch
this
starting tomorrow we don't have to wear
masks anymore
is anybody excited
yeah remember when they told us that uh
oh it's no big deal to have the kids
wear the mask they don't care they're
fine they don't mind
no it turns out when you when you force
anyone to muzzle their faces for hours a
day every single day it's it's a rather
unpleasant experience a lot worse than
unpleasant actually
for kids it is legitimately
psychologically traumatizing
and
there's no undoing the trauma now by the
way
you can't just flip a switch and it's
over
that's why when i watch videos like that
um
it's it makes you happy to see that
that the kids are finally being freed
from their muzzles
but it's also infuriating when you think
that
the reason they're so excited is that
they have been abused this way for the
last two years
and that's why we there's there can't be
any forgiveness here
you know among among leaders and
lawmakers who are responsible for this
and now they're changing their tune
we have to always remember it and never
forgive it ever
which is easy also because they're not
even asking for forgiveness
they're not admitting that they were
wrong now instead what they're telling
us is that uh oh you know we don't need
the masks anymore because things have
changed with covid or uh you know we've
learned certain things no as i've been
saying all along we we have learned
really nothing
we haven't learned anything about masks
everything we know about masks today
all of that information was available
before kovitt
um
and yeah we've we've learned about covet
as we've gone along but most of what we
know about kovid today we also knew
almost
at the almost at the very start
especially the fact that it doesn't it
does not impact kids nearly to the
nearly to the extent that it impacts
older adults
that's one of the enduring facts of
covert that we knew almost right away
and it hasn't changed
so the changes in policy now they have
nothing to do with things that we've
learned so we haven't really learned
much that we didn't already know
and they also are not in response to any
kind of
changing circumstance as far as the
virus goes they're in response to
changing political circumstances and
social circumstances
but the virus is still out there
you know they're
i don't know how many cases there are a
day now but it's it's close to peak
um thousands and thousands of cases new
cases a day
what they're finally
uh
relenting the fact that they're finally
being forced to relent to and submit to
is that um is that it's just
as some of us have been saying for years
now covet is always going to be with us
so at a certain point either we're going
to have these measures in place forever
or at a certain point we're just going
to stop
and if we just stop at a certain point
then that's always going to be arbitrary
and it's always going to be the case
that we never really had to do this at
all
so don't let these people get away with
it um don't forgive them
for it
and i also don't forgive the people even
people outside the government that were
pushing these measures
it's one thing in the in the very early
weeks and months of the of the pandemic
when this was new for everyone and
everyone was kind of out of sorts and
trying to make sense of it and
everything like that um
that's one thing but
people that as recently as a few months
ago were still pushing this
i don't i don't forgive them
i never will
you know when kids started killing
themselves
we've known about that for a long time
that was happening last year
if that wasn't enough for you
if that didn't convince you
and then you had your your
moment of of recognition
when the when the clouds opened up and
and the sun poked through and that
happened like last week
it's too late
in my view
this is from the daily wire there's a
new disney junior show called rise up
sing out includes an episode with a song
designed to teach preschoolers about
racial microaggressions in the latest
woke effort by the network
the song speak up features a young child
who is surprised that another child has
a parent with darker skin
and that launches into a song and i know
you're hoping that you'll get a chance
to hear the song and you will here it is
bye mom hey gabrielle i didn't know that
was your mom your skin is so much darker
than hers hold it did that comment make
you feel uncomfortable
that's a microaggression what's a
microaggression a microaggression is
when someone says it does something that
makes me feel bad sometimes just this
isn't a race but you know what he's
wrong
you should be proud of your skin it's
what makes you you
i
[Music]
know what to do
[Music]
so microaggressions by the way kids if
there's any kids watching this um a
microaggression
that uh what they're calling a
microaggression that is actually
when someone says something to you
that they didn't mean
to be offensive but for whatever reason
you're offended by it
that's actually that's what they mean
when they say microaggression that's why
it's that's why it's micro right
it's now if someone says something to
you that they're that they that they
intend to be offensive they're trying to
insult you that's not a microaggression
that's just aggression they're being
aggressive in their words so a
microaggression is when someone says
something they didn't mean they didn't
mean to offend you but for whatever
reason
you're offended by it
and you know what you should do in
response to that now you don't need to
break out into song about it you don't
need to go run and tell anybody
um you don't need to go talk to your
lawyers or your parents lawyers um you
know no no the the correct response is
to j is to is to move on
okay is to immediately move on with your
life
now you could always ask them too
so rather than going into the song and
dance you could just ask the person oh
hey
what did you mean by that
yeah that that hurt my feelings did was
that is that what you were trying to do
and if they say oh no i didn't mean to
hurt your feelings i don't mean anything
by it
then the correct response from you is oh
okay
and then go live your life just move on
with your life that's all that's the
beauty of it
because the thing is every you're you're
going to encounter stuff like that every
single day
that's that's just part of human
interaction
every day you're going to have awkward
conversations with people
and and especially because when you're
encountering a new person you don't know
that well
and you don't know them they don't know
you
we all have our own little particular
specific hang-ups and pet peeves and
not not everyone people don't know that
when they first encounter so they're
just being themselves
and and they don't know what your
buttons are that they that they they
should avoid pushing
and so you just you just move on with
your life that's all you have to do
very very simple
and in fact if someone says something to
you that they did not mean to be
offensive
and you take you choose to take offense
buy it if you choose to be offended by
it
then now that's on you
so actually now you're the bad guy
you you're you are choosing to take it
there
and now that it's 100 your fault
in fact microaggressions are they're
basically glorified pet peeves
and it's the same thing with a pet peeve
you know pet peeve is a is something
that it's a basically innocuous thing
that someone might do that for whatever
reason annoys you
and that's your problem
if it's innocuous and it's kind of
normal and we all have stuff like that
things people do that kind of annoys
well that's that's that's your problem
it's not anybody else's problem
so the example they give in that song is
someone uh is uh
another example someone comments on the
girl's hair
there's nothing wrong with someone
making a comment about your hair
if that offends you it's your problem
now that's the message to kids and to
adults but but specifically to adults
every time something like this comes up
with like the disney channel and there's
another
another uh episode or song and dance you
know
indoctrinating kids into the woke
ideology the leftist ideology you always
have parents who are
respond to this i'm seeing some of the
reactions on social media parents that
are shocked and surprised by it
well if you're if you're still allowing
your kid to watch the disney chat how
many of the of these kinds of things do
you need to see before you stop putting
the disney channel on for your kid
what you need to understand is that all
all
of the mainstream kid shows if they're
if they're you know owned by disney or
any of these big
companies
all of them
are going this direction
they either already are hopelessly woke
or they will be very soon every single
one none of them are safe just you
should just know that
same thing is happening with all with
with all
uh
shows and films for kids and for adults
you know we're getting more information
now about the lord of the rings
uh series the that they've spent like a
billion i think literally a billion
dollars they've spent on this thing for
the lord of the rings series series for
amazon
and we haven't seen a trailer yet but
they've got you know they're leaking
more information about it we've started
to see some of the characters and some
of the some of the plot details and
actors and everything
and uh yet again you see on social media
the reaction from some conservatives
saying oh i hope this is good i hope it
isn't woke i don't know and they're
no it is definitely going to be woke 100
it's amazon
spending a billion dollars on a
lord of the rings series what do you
think they're gonna do
what have have respect for the original
material
no they have no respect for it
they're not capable they don't think
that they that they even can
just tell a story anymore they're always
going to be these elements
so
abandon all hope when it comes to
franchises
in general tv movies in general unless
you're a daily wire member and then you
can watch all of our entertainment
properties that are not woke at all all
right um let's see what else do we got
here
cnn is still trying to sort through this
joe rogan situation and they put out a
tweet yesterday
says joe rogan is one of the most
popular podcast hosts in the world
despite a series of controversies cnn
business spoke with a researcher who has
studied his appeal to explain why his
audience loves him
and so they've brought in a researcher
to figure out why do people like joe
rogan so much and here's what they came
up with watch this
the joe rogan experience joe rogan hosts
one of the most popular podcasts in the
world i'm not i'm not an anti-vaxx
person right but despite his claims he's
used his platform to make false and
inaccurate statements about covet 19 in
vaccines if you're a healthy person and
you're exercising all the time and
you're young and you're eating well and
like i don't think you need to worry
about this he's also used racist and
offensive language we get out and we're
giggling oh you see plenty games we walk
into planet of the apes
we walked into africa dude even with
these controversies rogan remains wildly
popular so the question is
why
i've probably spent hundreds of hours
listening to joe rogan yeah no easily
hundreds of hours gabriel wisniewski
parks is a research fellow at unc
greensboro who has studied rogan's
appeal what makes him so magnetic to his
audience is his very vocal resistance to
tribalism this is somebody who can have
on his podcast ben shapiro and alex
jones and have deep and interesting
meaningful conversations with them and
then in the one other breath he can have
on cornell west and bernie sanders and
do the exact same thing and this really
resonates with people and one other
connection we can make that i don't
think should be overestimated is joe
rogan's background as a stand-up
comedian this archetype of the comedian
as the truth-teller
of course they had to bring this dork in
there to uh
research and find out because cnn is
they are they are absolutely stumped
um
they don't understand how to get people
to watch things obviously you know
because they they only have five viewers
and so they're looking at joe rogan and
uh we know there's a lot of a lot of
envy that plays into it
but they also are sort of interested
from a scientific perspective
how does this guy do do this
and so they have to bring in a joe rogan
researcher to tell them
and what are his findings well um he's
funny people like funny things
and people like comedians you know they
like to laugh
so we needed a phd candidate
you know we needed to bring him in he
needed to spend hundreds of hours
researching
i would love by the way to be a fly on
the wall uh watching as
that researcher
is you know listening to joe rogan
subjecting himself into it to it in
order to research it
just crying probably sobbing
uncontrollably at everything that he's
hearing that would be fantastic
um but after all of his research they
he's discovered that uh people like to
laugh
wow
and also um people like to hear you know
different interesting conversations and
they like to hear from different sorts
of people
you know i could have told you that
without listening to any joe rogan at
all
and whatever you're paying your rogan
researcher i'll you could pay me half of
that
and i'll listen to joe rogan's podcast
and give you similar insights
um
all right
i've been debating whether we're even
going to put this up on the screen i
don't know if i can put it up on the
screen or what we're i don't know what's
going to pop up here but um
do we have the okay adidas put out this
ad do we have the actual do we have a
picture can we put the picture up there
we don't have the okay we don't the
picture well then there's no point of
this um adidas put out an ad for their
bras i think their sports bras
and uh you could go to twitter if you
really want to find it and it's just
it's uh 25 pairs of breasts
naked breasts that they just put up
there on twitter which
apparently nudity is allowed on twitter
they you know the account didn't get
removed or anything i'll put that tweet
back up i gotta read that tweet um and
then they're they're justifying why they
did this because this is to advertise
sports bras right
so they put naked breasts up there
it really makes me fearful of whenever
they decide to advertise their um jock
straps like what's going to happen then
but you know
why why are if you're going to go that
route why would the breasts not why
would wouldn't you put bras when they
have bras on because that's what you're
advertising
well they're explaining this they say
breasts breasts are a natural part of
the anatomy it's time to remove the
stigma to allow future generations to
flourish
so they put 25 breasts up there to allow
future generations to flourish
remove the stigma
what stigma is there around breasts
where have you encountered a stigma
i'll tell you where there's a stigma
actually there is this i tell you who's
stigmatizing uh the female female
breasts and the female form generally
well that would be uh the
sex change surgeons who are chopping the
breasts off of
uh young young women to try to turn them
into boys
you know the thousands of young women
who are being indoctrinated and groomed
and then subjected to that kind of
butchery
that's where the stigmatization of
breasts is going on but anywhere else i
don't think it's really being
stigmatized
but the interesting thing about that
photo is um
which you can't really see at all on the
show but if you go you can see it's it's
it looks almost like it's it's weirdly
kind of clinical because it's it's like
these disembodied all you're seeing are
disembodied torsos
it looks like they look like
snapshots you would find in a serial
killer's basement they look like they
look like photos from a morgue or
something
and so they've managed to take the
female form and make it look like creepy
and weird
i don't know maybe maybe this is part
maybe there really is a conspiracy to
turn everyone gay um
this ad is part of it but it's they
managed to take the female form and make
it
that's what i first thought it's like
did you get these pictures at a morgue
or something like that
so while they're trying to
allegedly celebrate the female form they
end up with this dehumanized kind of
disembodied
thing
that just looks
creepy
and uh and disgusting that's part of
what we see in our culture now
of um
of
on one hand the left they're
everything is sexualized
and they seem to be obsessed with sort
of presenting the human you know the
human body and it's in all of its naked
glory
but at the same time they also hate sex
and they hate the human body
and so those these two things sort of
exist in tension and my final point here
also is
isn't it interesting that you never see
this kind of thing all jokes aside about
their jock jockstrap ad
that ad is never coming out thank god
but you never see this kind of thing
with men really
because in the in the ad with all the
breasts they also have you know it's
pretty clear that they're that some of
these women are quite overweight and so
their you know breasts are appearing as
well in the end
all of the kind of body positivity and
let's let's show off naked people it's
it's always women if you notice never
men
we're never celebrating fat guys
something else to ponder as well you
know with the ever increasing numbers of
car makes and models it's impossible
these days to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
so what happens is you go to the
storefront and you go inside the store
and you're looking for what you want and
uh they don't have it they ask you all
kinds of questions and you're gonna say
i can't answer those questions because
i'm not a real man because i don't know
anything about cars and then the guy
behind the counter is gonna laugh at you
while he goes and orders the parts
anyway on his computer and then tells
all his friends what a girly man you are
you could have avoided this just by
going to rockauto.com at home
um you could pull your phone out of your
pocket and just do it that way
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com and shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door the rockauto.com catalog is unique
and very easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are extremely low all the
time the selection is great as well so
uh what are you waiting for all the
parts you ever need at rockauto.com go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and write walsh in their how did you
hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
let's get now to our comment section
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you go to
dailywire.com sweet baby comments to
leave a video comment and let's uh take
a look at some of these play let's play
clip go to 14 first
sweet daddy walsh uh as a person of
height i find it greatly oppressive
whenever i go into a store and they
don't have long enough shirts or pants
unfortunately unlike people of size i
cannot change that fact
also i have a new son and i was
wondering if you have any tips on
stopping the pea fountain
that ultimately always ends with getting
on the walls sweet baby game crew oh
well as to the last question there's
nothing you could do there really isn't
it's just don't even
just accept the fact if you have a if
you have a son if you have a little boy
in the house um there's going to be pee
all over everything everywhere
especially in the bathroom
and you could you you can try to do what
you can to stem the tide as it were
uh and control the problem but it's it's
i've discovered after two sons it's it's
it's hopeless you just have to accept so
much of parenting
um to
maintain your sanity
you know and find joy in parenting a lot
of it starts with acceptance
right
it's the first stage is acceptance you
just have to accept this is what your
life is and when you have a young boy
yeah it's just going to pee everywhere
that's just the way it's going to be
um
as to the quote that's the point about
tall people being oppressed i actually
think that's you know you have as good
an argument as anybody for for being
oppressed
and for some reason tall people are
never included short people sometimes
but tall people are never included in
the in the oppressed minority
but you think about when you're tall the
physical inconvenience the way that you
know
the difficulty you said in finding
clothing the way that uh rooms are not
really built for your massive size
you try to i'm not even all that tall i
mean i'm tall i'm above average height
but um i'm not like freakishly tall but
even for me you try to sit on an
airplane it's almost impossible
and then you have people making comments
all the time don't talk about
microaggressions
you're a very tall person everywhere you
go your whole life people comment on it
so i agree with you sir i think you have
i think you have a case to be made for
your own victimhood and you should make
it
uh because everybody else does all right
a couple of written comments uh da
broseph says oh my goodness could you
imagine living a day in someone's mind
that overthinks emojis that much my dad
who is white always uses black emojis
i assume that he didn't know how to
correct his settings and never thought
about it again unfortunately i've now
realized my dad is the reincarnation of
of
hitler uh that's also well of course
he's he is but if he's a white guy then
he's already basically hitler it's not
but it's also really funny to me the the
thought that uh your white dad is using
the black emojis because he can't figure
out how to change the settings
definitely don't help him
you're doing the right thing here just
leave him leave him to that
and it's a good lesson for him to learn
because why is your dad
as an adult
male using emojis in the first place
uh jessica says heads would have
exploded if the degenerate masses had
heard our pastor's sermon last week he
called out porn use homosexuality spoke
about men not women being called to lead
god's church
it gave me chills it was all i could do
not to applaud he also did it in the
most fatherly loving way not
self-righteously or mean not because of
true love and
or rather but because of true love and
concern
for the
people yeah that's it's the funny thing
is if you you if you're a christian
um and you love some people
then you you want them to be holy and
you want them to go to heaven
and so you're going to tell them things
that will help them in that
journey
um this is what pastors are supposed to
do but it is it is very scandalous and
surprising for a lot of people even
christians
because many people they could go their
whole life at any any time they happen
to wander into a church on the rare
occasion that they do they never hear
any messages like this they never hear a
word about sin
during sermons and homilies
um and then they finally hear they think
what is this no this this is what church
is supposed to be
uh what else we got
sarah says matt i've recently changed my
views on the whole purity culture way of
thinking i'm very conservative in my
views and a christian but i no longer
believe in blaming women for men's
thoughts men are absolutely capable of
controlling their minds and what they
think i think there's a huge difference
between lusting and noticing a woman and
i think we often make men feel bad for
noticing putting it on women to make
sure men don't lust is ridiculous some
men have a thing for feet some men have
a thing for legs some for shoulders or
necks i recently found out about someone
i know who struggled not to lust after
fully clothed normal women walking down
the street on a daily basis
even in countries when women are
completely covered
even in countries where women are
completely covered rapes are very common
men who choose to will lust regardless
of what someone is wearing often modesty
is dependent on the culture in some
countries it's completely normal for
women to walk around topless and other
countries you can't even show your face
i also don't think that he um lumped in
women giving birth with women wearing
bikinis
if a man can't control his thoughts
looking at birth photos then he's not a
safe person to be around these are a
bunch of random thoughts that i have
about this topic highly recommend the
book the great sex rescue that is all
okay
um
here's here's the difference though
here's the point i think it's a very
simple point
and again we're we are speaking as
christians right
i i fully acknowledge that if you're not
a christian if you're a secular person
any disgust you're going to find any
discussion of modesty to be
fundamentally ridiculous
and um that's a different conversation
that's not the conversation we're having
right now
because that's someone who's even more
hopeless right and that's that's a
longer conversation but talking among
christians um
then i think it becomes very simple
is that that you should not be doing
anything
where you are explicitly attempting
to lead someone into sin in their
thoughts and so i use the example which
i think is a good example because it's
another it's another way that modesty is
supposed to be applied
because i would agree with you that
the message about modesty i think it's
good to talk about modesty
and as and talk about modesty as it
pertains to what you wear
but that's that shouldn't be the entire
message because there are other ways
where people could be immodest
and so i gave the
example yesterday if someone showing off
you know their their the things that
they buy and be very ostentatious and
kind of showing off their wealth and the
reason why people do that
is because they're trying to make other
people envious
now if you just buy a car because you
need a new car and you buy this car
because you like it and that's why you
bought it because you like the car and
it's the car that you need and you want
and you're driving down the street and
someone happens to see it and it just so
happens that they really want that car
too and they feel envious well you
didn't do anything wrong
but if you say oh you know i want that
car because that's going to show off how
rich i am that's going to make everybody
really envious of me
if you do that then that's wrong because
you're trying to engender those feelings
in somebody else
so i think we could apply the same kind
of concept to what to to dress to what
you wear
so if you're just dressing in regular
clothing and you're walking down the
street
and someone's lusting after you that's
obviously not your fault
but when you put on clothing because
you're because you're trying to attract
that kind of attention you're trying to
create those sorts of uh feelings and
thoughts in someone else's mind
then as a christian it should be pretty
obvious that that's wrong
so
i don't know there we go now we can
agree hopefully
that uh i'm right and you're wrong about
this well if you missed the world
premiere of shut-in last night then you
seriously missed out not only did we get
to share a film too gritty and thrilling
for hollywood but we were able to tease
out our next big film terror on the
prairie which is a western starring none
other than the great gina carano we
couldn't be more excited to be making
good on our promise of bringing you real
entertainment and for the for the over
half a million that tuned in
half a million people we seriously hope
you enjoyed as much as we did if you
missed it don't worry it's streaming on
our website for members only and if
you're not a member head to
dailywire.com subscribe and enter code
shut in for 30 off your membership today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know often i like to use this
segment for a bit of levity talking
about things that are perhaps not as
serious a bit more frivolous
especially on a friday but but sometimes
the news cycle forces me to wade into
deeper and more serious waters and deal
with true tragedies and outrages
that's what brings us to the rapper jim
jones not to be confused with the cult
leader jim jones with the we know the
poison kool-aid we have to drink a
different kind of kool-aid when we
encounter this story the kool-aid of
injustice headlines from outlets like
yahoo and the independent tell us that
jim jones was recently the victim of
racial profiling at the gucci store in
manhattan
but that doesn't tell the whole story
not even close as it turns out jones was
with fellow rapper five mikes going to
various designer stores while filming a
video for their latest song going
shopping
now of course going shopping sounds like
the name of a song the spice girls would
have made in 1997
but that's not the case jones and five
mikes are grown men who who happened to
love shopping and they wanted to make a
song about it and on this particular day
they visited louis vuitton bergdorf
goodman whatever that is
and um bergdorf is that a is that a
fancy clothing shop people people
intentionally wear clothing bergdorf
okay and a number of other stores
while uh buying things and singing about
how much they love shopping everything
was fine until they made it to gucci
and i will now let jones tell the story
in his own words and i warn you
that this is very difficult to hear
we've been in gucci for about an hour
right and we're in gucci in the vip
for like two hours right since we came
in here having nobody came and showed us
no courtesy no amenities no nothing
period not even a drink of water
pause it there so that we can digest
what we've heard so far
uh jim jones and five mikes are in the
vip section of gucci
you may not have realized that stores
have vip sections but they do and that's
where the most victimized people end up
you might even call it the viv section
very important victims and jones and
five mics are there literally dying of
thirst
they've been in the viv section for an
hour maybe even two hours without any
form of sustenance
they're on the verge of death when jim
jones finally pulls out his phone to
bravely document what might prove to be
his last words on earth
his tale of suffering only gets more
harrowing from there listen to this
actually speak to a manager
send me a black guy out here to start
telling me some [ __ ] so they got the
black guy racial profiling on black
people i had to speak to a manager
bigger than him everybody disappeared
ain't nobody come out yet i still ain't
getting i still ain't get no sparkling
water i still ain't getting no champagne
i still ain't getting nothing
i didn't have a salesperson inside of my
vip suite the whole time i was there i
had to keep screaming for vip people to
help me out now everybody don't know
where the real manager is you heard it's
it's time i'm tired of this we're
spending all this money as entertainers
inside these stores they hire these
black people and these black people are
more racist than white people when they
get their job
inside of gucci all of a sudden you
stop playing with us bro
still haven't seen a manager yet
he's tireless he's not going to take it
anymore
won't someone speak up for the
entertainers in the vip section of gucci
it's even worse than i thought it's not
that this man had been deprived of
regular water
i mean what's regular water gonna do for
him anyway regular water might be
acceptable for washing your hands or
watering the grass but you can't drink
the stuff
jim jones required sparkling water and
yet none was provided to him in a timely
fashion
they couldn't even scrounge up any
champagne for the poor guy again you may
not have realized that getting served
champagne by customer service at a
retail store was even an option but it
is and i can tell you that i walked into
walgreens last week and i shot into the
cashier yes i have arrived please fetch
me some champagne and caviar and within
three minutes i was sitting at a table
by candlelight in the moisturizer
section whining and dining but then
again i'm white this is the kind of
treatment white people get everywhere we
go
jim jones is a black man at gucci
spending he says thirty thousand dollars
on clothes and shoes
he doesn't have any privilege at all
he is such a victim that even other
black people are racist against him the
race is against him by their failure to
submissively serve his every whim in
need now you might say that from the
sound of it if anything he is racist
against them but you only say that
because you're you are also racist
against jim jones you do not have his
lived experience
like the lived experience of spending 30
grand on designer clothing in one day
something that only the most oppressed
among us are able to do
fortunately thank god uh jones and five
mikes
did survive this experience um somehow
later jones posted an update to social
media he wrote quote
gucci really some suckers and for those
looking from the outside saying this is
some rich privilege
it's really not it's about treating
people with respect no matter the race
or what you may think you know about a
person and for people saying that
spending money foolishly you never know
what a person been through so
you should never worry about what a
person does with his
very well put
it's none of your business how much
money he spends
which is why he posted a video to
instagram telling everyone how much
money he spent
you simply cannot know what this man has
been through until he complains about it
publicly which he does a lot apparently
and to think that jones would be put
through this ordeal during black history
month no less
it's the sort of thing that fills you
with disgust and rage down to the pit of
your being
you know when i was in that third world
country last week and i i thought those
people were suffering
but i guarantee none of them here's what
i can tell you for sure none of them
have ever received poor customer service
at gucci
their lives are blessed beyond measure
in comparison to jim jones and his
friend five mikes in fact speaking of
his friend from what i hear they were so
deprived and suffered such deprivation
at gucci
that by the time they left five mikes
was only three mikes
that was bad i'm sorry about that one
i know there's nothing i can do right
now uh to heal this wrong that uh jim
jones has suffered but but i'll i'll be
doing my part at least by boycotting
gucci stores from here on out in fact
i've been boycotting gucci my whole life
in preparation for this moment i have
literally never purchased a single gucci
item
and i tell you right now i promise you i
never will
it's the least i can do
and i can also say taguchi and all of
its employees with righteous fury
you scoundrels are canceled
that'll do it for us today and for the
week have a great weekend talk to you on
monday godspeed
[Music]
matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
shows the daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin